we heard earlier from Michael Gove who
was very explicit saying that this
government will not be granting a second
referendum on Scottish independence what
did she make of it
oh really I think Boris Johnson has to
recognize the situation that we're in we
won the election in Scotland we have 45
percent of the vote we've got 80 percent
of the seats in Scotland the
Conservatives only stood on one issue in
north of the border that wasn't stopping
an independence referendum they've gone
down from 13 seats to 7 they lost
they're going to accept they lost that
would not accept to the SNP won the
election and we fought the servation on
the basis of the people in Scotland
being given the right to choose their
own future we already have a mandate for
a referendum on independence we won that
to the election to the Scottish
Parliament in 2016
they're going to have to recognise the
people in Scotland have spoken this is
about democracy Boris Johnson she's
recognized that that parikamma
referendum should not sit with Boris
Johnson should sit with the Scottish
Parliament acting in the best interest
of all the people of Scotland at the
same time they the Conservative Party
stood on a manifesto and again 180 seat
majority that ruled out another
referendum manifesto page 45 we are
opposed to a second independence
referendum so they have a mandate to
deny as well no they don't have a
mandate in Scotland they lost in
Scotland they've lost seven of the 13
seats they got the rejection of the
people of Scotland that don't want to be
taken out to the Union you didn't get a
majority either you won 45 percent of
the votes in Scotland as you said that
doesn't give you an over 50 percent
mandate either we had we've got 45
percent of the vote the Tories are
trailing in our way 21 they're not the
only party standing in Scotland who is
Pro Union but the point is we've
actually got a bigger Mandi the bigger
majority than Boris Johnson does to
deliver brexit we've got 80 percent of
the seats from Scotland and you know
this is not going to look great for the
Tories if they're going to turn right
into Scotland if you're going to see the
people in Scotland can vote however they
like but that the conservators and Boris
Johnson are going to determine our
future you know we were told in 2014
that if we stayed in the United Kingdom
their rights as EU citizens were going
to be respected Boris Johnson's taking
us out of Europe against our will
all
is happening through the intransigence
of the Conservative Party by refusing to
accept democracy by refusing to accept
the right discourse to choose that is
driving more and more people to support
the Scottish National Party that's what
will happen you know when you hear
various 20 politicians I want to Jack
the Secretary of State for Scotland did
say in the election campaign they
recognised optimally Scotland's right to
choose many labour politicians have come
out and said the same thing
many media commentators have recognized
that ultimately that the Conservatives
can't see say no when the people of
Scotland demonstrate that they want to
have that independence referendum Boris
Johnson's going to have to listen okay
let's have a quick look at the timings
because Nicola Sturgeon says that she
wants to send out the section 30 order
which is the official power to hold an
independence referendum before the end
of the year yeah it's not long when's it
coming this week this week yep what day
well you'll see well we're not gonna
know it's probably good today but they
will be happening this week that would
be making the case that that power
should be transferred that's democracy
that's right we won the election Boris
Johnson should respect that and what
happens if the concept is just ignore it
is there anything you can do but at the
end of the day I wouldn't take anything
Boris Johnson says that his worth it
changes his mind and everything he's
going to recognize that the SNP are
speaking for the people of Scotland we
win this election
45% of the vote 80% of the seats this
issue is not going to go away we will
win that right to have that referendum
Scottish independence this will happen
even let's set the reality of that and
accept that sooner rather than later
well let's try and work out how about we
get to that point because we know don't
we really then you're going to send this
section 30 order and it's going to be
rejected by the government so what
happens then well let's wait and see
what's in the letter that the First
Minister sends on behalf of the Scottish
Government later this week Michael Joe
just told me a few moments ago that they
are going to reject it
well what does that say about democracy
that the government in London is saying
to the people in Scotland we're going to
ignore MPs that you send to Westminster
if we don't ignore your government
because let's not forget that we were
told in 2014 that this was a family of
Nations the Scotland's place the union
was to be respected and yet here we have
the Conservative government saying we're
going to ignore the democratically
elected government of Scotland
it's not a great lookk Sophie is it
could you hold a referendum without the
approval of politicians we have instead
we have a plan that we're progressing
with with just student election we've
won that election the plan is working
the plan will be delivered on
Westminster is going to have to
recognize the right thing to do as was
done last time round when we have the
Edmund I agreement is to do this in the
way that respects the Scottish
Parliament the respects the Scottish
Government and respects the people of
Scotland that have supported the SNP
just gonna ask again so I'm still not
totally clear if the UK government the
Westminster Government keeps saying no
could you hold a second referendum on
independence without that Commission I
don't think many people believe that the
UK government can keep saying no or
there are conservatives that have
accepted that you know we had a very
senior Labour politician and Scot when
yesterday the president of Kosovo the
local government body that accepted the
Scotland has the right to choose more
and more people are recognizing that if
you've got a chance and well not he look
like
you must have gained out this scenario
what's the only thing we've looked at
all options let's wait and see when we
put the letter to the government this
week we have an irrefutable case we have
a mandate that was given to us in 2016
we have the support of the Scottish
people conservatives I'm not going to be
able to continue saying no that won't
work Boris Johnson has to accept reality
we will have that referendum and it
would be better for all concerned that
we do this in a timely manner with no
desire to see us taking her to the
European Union let's have that
referendum in 2020 we will win this
argument we will win this case we will
have that referendum and I confidently
predict that Scotland will become an
independent member of the European Union
let me just have a quick look at some
polling that was done in the Sunday
Times this is last weekend now the
question that was asked was if the
Conservative Party wins the election
which they have and says there should
not be another referendum on
independence in Scotland which they have
what do you think the Scottish
government should do 47% says accept the
decision 29% try to overturn it in the
courts 14% try to hold another
independence referendum nice most people
in these chants say you should just
accept the decision I think when you
look at most of the polling over the
course of the last few weeks and months
what polls also show that
Scotland's taken out of the European
Union the majority of people in Scotland
that have a mrs. so throughout the
United Kingdom recognize the Scotland's
right to choose its own future more and
more people will recognize that we have
to protect ourselves we need to make
sure that Scotland can grow its economy
we need to make sure that we have access
to free movement of people many people
will see that Scotland would have a
destination in Europe with independence
the sands are shifting there is a shift
towards support for independence that's
what's very clearly reflective and all
the polling evidence that was seen over
the course of the last few weeks and
months just looking and the election
result across the United Kingdom you
clearly the largest party in Scotland
yeah in Northern Ireland we've seen more
Pro nationalist MPs elected than
unionists for the first time ever do you
feel that the this is the beginning I
guess of the breakup of the United
Kingdom you know many people went up or
a few months ago Sophie said that
conservatives would accept to break up
in the United Kingdom if it means
delivering brexit we can't sit back and
allow ourselves to be torn out I think
whether it's in Scotland or other parts
of the United Kingdom people will
reflect on this this is the end of the
Union Scotland will be joining the
European Union the only question is the
exact timing and the mechanisms of that
we are on a journey and that journey
will reach this end and that journey
will be Scottish independence will it be
before the next election no our next
general election well we have a mandate
we have that mandate from 2016 has just
been reinforced Boris Johnson should
accept we should know get on with it
okay thank you very much for coming into
the studio today and laying out some of
your plan yeah in the coming will be
more this week and I look forward to
speaking speaking with you about that in
the days and the weeks to come okay
thank you very much for being on the
program thank you